more states they are letting businesses
open up and pressure from the president
for schools to reopen as well at least
21 different states have now eased
various restrictions in many cases
without meeting federal guidelines on
the decline in the reported illnesses
Tony and that includes Texas the second
largest economy in the u.s. the new
policy there starts Friday that would be
May 1st and it involves a wide range of
businesses but not schools at least not
so far Janet shamlian is at the house of
pies that's in Houston
Janet good morning so will the house be
open for people sitting down to eat on
Friday Toni good morning to you well
it's open for take-out only right now
but come Friday they are gonna be
seating people here around the clock as
the states restrictions are loosened and
it comes as other states are making
similar decisions right now they are
weighing economic viability versus
saving lives
Texas is open for business starting
Friday the Lone Star State will allow
restaurants retailers movie theaters and
malls to operate at 25% capacity under
strict social distancing guidelines we
need to confirm but the state's daily
Kovach cases have been hovering in the
high triple digits for most of the past
week at least one dallas restaurant
owner says he won't be opening Friday
even though we can I'd rather take our
time getting back and make sure that
that curve is fully flattened or on its
decrease before having another outbreak
that the government would then decide to
shut down once more in Georgia many
restaurant table sat empty even though
dining areas reopened Monday at others a
glimpse of life post quarantine our
servers our bartenders they'll be
wearing masks there's hand sanitizer
that's able to be used
we have disposable menus this montana
mall was also back in business with a
small but steady stream of customers I
think that largely most of the folks are
observing the social distancing
meanwhile in Ohio retail stores are set
to open May 12 with protections in place
President Trump suggested Monday that
states could consider reopening schools
before the end of the academic year but
43 states in Washington DC have already
ordered or recommended school buildings
remain closed I think it would be a good
thing because as you see in terms of
what this vicious virus goes after of
young people seem to do very well but
teachers and school officials are very
concerned about that they say it could
be close to impossible to keep students
6 feet apart in school here in Texas the
governor is planning to increase testing
so far about 290 thousand tests have
been done sounds like a lot but it's
only about one percent of the state's
nearly 30 million people
Anthony Janet thank you